je veux juste savoir est-ce que vous
prenez toujours la destruction de l'État
d'Israël vous parlez de destruction
d'Israël mais nous nous parlons de
mettre fin à une occupation israélienne
de notre
[Musique]
terre le visage du Hamas est d'abord
celui de ces kamikas ces bombes humaines
élevé au rang de Marty pour avoir commis
des attentats suicides en Israël une
centaine d'opérations sanglantes
perpétrées par les brigades des martyres
d'alaxa la branche armée du
Hamas le Hamas le mouvement de la
résistance islamique bâti sur les
pierres de la première Intifada en 87
par le cheik Yassine l'idéologue en
chaise roulante qu'Israël élimine en
2004 c'est inscrit dans sa charte le
Hamas prône la destruction de l'État
d'Israël et reconna pas son exist cet
objectif de détruire Israël a disparu de
son programme électoral mais lorsque
l'on pose directement la question à un
des dirigeants du Hamas il
esquive je veux juste savoir est-ce que
vous prenez toujours la destruction de
l'État
d'Israël vous parlez de destruction
d'Israël mais nous nous parlons de
mettre fin à une occupation israélienne
de notre terre
le score du Hamas surprend aujourd'hui
mais depuis des années sa popularité se
mesure à l'ône des foules immense qui
assiste aux obsèques des terroristes
martyres une popularité bâtie sur un
solide réseau d'êide social prise en
charge des orphelins financement de
mariage de nécessiteux et surtout un
endoctrinement qui commence dès le plus
jeune âge au Hamas les femmes Mar de
martyr ont aussi leur place c'est par
que passe l'islamisation à outrance
depuis sa victoire aux élections
municipales de l'an dernier le Hamas
observe une trêve dans les attentat et s
force de faire oublier ses armes sans
jamais toutefois parler de les
[Musique]
déposer